Brad Cohen's with us right now the
Kennedy County Texas sheriff sheriff the
numbers look daunting if they're even
partly accurate here that we could see a
staggering wave of migrants make their
way here and a lot of them buoyed by
these Tick Tock and other missives that
seem to say it's okay the border is open
what do you make of that and how they'll
likely respond to that
well good afternoon uh since Biden has
said then bite Administration has taken
over the borders never really been truly
secure but this wave of Titan 42 going
away is going to make things very
extremely difficult in my County because
it's already started it started last
Friday we started seeing the heat influx
causing through our area and through our
local ranches last Friday we pulled over
a hundred off one freight train we had a
report but there were some passages
right on top of the Grain cars we got
down there we pulled over close to 200
off that train and that is far from
normal
sure let me ask you one of the things
the administration and Homeland Security
secretary mayorka said mentioned just a
couple of hours ago was uh the
implementation of something called a
Transit ban now this would make it so
that migrants who cross into the U.S
without permission well they would be
ineligible for Asylum and therefore
quickly deported
um we've already seen cases where this
so-called honor System was broken and as
soon as they're deported they're back in
the United States back and forth back
and forth back and forth do you have any
faith in in something like that a
Transit ban
no not whatsoever because like you just
said they keep coming back you send them
back they come back send them back they
come back there's no consequences until
the federal government starts uh doing
the prosecution and attaching the
consequences to their actions we're just
that's what we're going to continue to
see so when they talk about offering the
incentive of the sheriff of those who
voluntarily go back uh need not wait
five years to try again in other words
if you're forcibly deported yet you've
come over and you're refusing to go back
to court then they'll say uh five years
before you can try again well to your
point they keep trying again so this
notion that going back voluntarily or
not is going to make a difference what
do you think
I don't think it's gonna make a
difference one where the the voluntary
return uh at one time was was a
sustainable deal for border patrol but
with these numbers it's going to have to
do they're going to have to go strictly
buy the book and do either the uh
actual removals or prosecute for illegal
entry to make everybody believe that hey
yes we are going to try to report his
lawyer um the sheriff as well I've told
a lot about this Tick Tock a message
that's gone out and apparently uh more
than 100 million have viewed it might be
substantially more than that now was
that is that earlier this afternoon and
uh under the the label titular 42 it
says uh right now the United States is
open the you are not going to be
deported title 42 has come to an end I
keep repeating this because this is what
the message is that's getting out to
these people who are reading this and
and I'm wondering these are the ones
they're trying to get in the United
States who've been told that it's okay
come on
um who's putting that out
that could be that's that's a good
question but I'm sure it's being
interpreted by the cartels in a separate
way right so that because they're going
to make money off this deal one way or
the other
so they feel emboldened by this title 42
goes away they've never been away
themselves this is going to beef up
their presence and actions to get more
activity at the border
I agree I agree 100 with that now what
kind of conditions are we looking at
then for those who presumably now feel
that they have that green light
especially along the Mexican border
where depending on the numbers you know
these better than I Sheriff you're
looking at 10 20 30 40 000 or more who
might feel that as soon as this this
ends they're in or they're going to try
to come in
well that's like you showed earlier the
Haitians are lining up there matamors
waiting for this to end so they will
over over uh whelm the system which will
give the cartels their opportunities to
use that in their favor to move uh those
that are susceptible to deportation are
those that don't want to go for
assignment want to live here in the
underground or in the shadows plus
bringing the Fentanyl and the
methamphetamines and everything else in
so it works for their benefit you know
Sheriff you know we're so used to
thinking in the past when we would have
border issues that this was a Mexico or
uh just a few countries as you've
reminded me in the past it represents
116 countries but Venezuela came to mind
and just the the period from 2015 to
today a quarter of that country's
population has abandoned the country we
see similar numbers out of Haiti and
Honduras and a host of other countries
Nicaragua comes to mind that the
conditions have turned so bad in their
countries uh that they are swarming the
Mexico Southern border uh and and that
that wave is what's undeniable in
building do you agree with that
oh I agree 100 uh of course the
Venezuelan government and their their
inflation is through the roof right uh
same thing with the Haitians the the
political environment there is fairly
corrupt so they're trying they're trying
to get away to make a better life for
themselves and I can understand that
but there's also legal ways to do it but
the cartels and others are taking
advantage of these people charging them
outrageous fortunes to just to get to
the Mexican border hey Sean Hannity here
hey click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else